if you can dodge a wrench you can dodge
a ball what
it's been two decades since the
so-called frat pack dominated Hollywood
comedy Ben Stiller and Vince Vaughn
stalwarts of that scene collaborated on
many mid-2000s movies perhaps most
notable of which was 2004's dodgeball A
True Underdog Story a broad and wacky
sports movie that simultaneously
satirizes sports movie cliches dodgeball
is a tale of good versus evil set on the
dodgeball court dodgeball wraps up
pretty conclusively but since it was a
massively profitable hit and an enduring
favorite on cable TV a sequel is on the
way regardless in April 2023 deadline
reported that 20th century Studios had
ordered another round of dodgeball the
binge screenwriter Jordan vandina Will
pen the script taking over from original
writer director Ross and Marshall
Thurber a director for this movie is yet
to be announced but Vaughn has already
agreed to reprise his role from the
first dodgeball having successfully
pitched his original idea for the movie
to vandina